>>> This just into CNN.
Former vice president Mike pence
just addressed the classified
documents that were found in his
home.
>> It's actually been a very
humbling week for us.
But I know we did the right
thing.
Look, the proper handling of
classiied information is very
important to the national
interest.
Throughout my career in the
congress and as your vice
president, we always sought to
take great care in the handling
of the nation's secrets.
At the close of our
administration, we did a
thorough review of all the
documents and the possessions in
the office of the vice
president, and the residence of
the vice president.
I'm confident that was conducted
in a professional manner, but
with news in recent weeks of
repeated disclosure of
classified documents in a
personal residence of president
Biden, and documents dating back
to his service as vice
president, I simply thought, out
of an abundance of caution, it
would be appropriate to review
my personal records kept at our
residence at the state of
Indiana.
We initiated that process.
Along the way, we determined
that there was a small number of
documents marked classified or
sensitive interspersed in my
personal papers.
Upon making that discovery, we
secured those documents
immediately.
We alerted the national
archives.
We turned them over to the FBI,
and soon thereafter communicated
it to congress.
While I was not aware that those
classified documents were in our
personal residence, let me be
clear.
Those classified documents
should not have been at my
personal residence.
Mistakes were made, and I take
full responsibility.
I've directed by counsel to work
with the national archives, with
the department of justice, and
with the congress to fully
cooperate in any investigation.
Our national security depends on
the proper handling of
classified and sensitive
materials, and I -- I know that
when errors are made, it's
important that they be resolved
swiftly and disclosed.
My only hope is that as the
American people look at our
conduct in this manner, that
they see that we acted above
politics, and put the national